mention par l'école le président de la
république l'a rappelé le retour de nos
enfants sur le chemin des écoles est un
impératif pédagogique un impératif de
justice sociale en particulier pour ceux
qui peuvent difficilement suivre
l'enseignement à distance
ce retour nous voulons le concilier avec
la préservation de nos objectifs de
santé publique
pour ce faire nous proposons une
réouverture très progressive des
maternelle et de l'école élémentaire à
compter du 11 mai partout sur le
territoire et sur la base du volontariat
dans un deuxième temps à compter du 18
mai mais seulement dans les départements
où la circulation du virus est très
faible
nous pourrons envisager d'ouvrir les
collèges en commençant par les classes
de 6e et de 5e
nous déciderons fin mais si nous pouvons
réouvrir les lycées en commençant par
les lycées professionnels
début juin cette décision n'a pas été
prise à la légère
nous avons consulté nous avons pesé le
pour et le contre
nous avons étudié ce que font les autres
pays mais la réouverture des écoles est
nécessaire pour garantir la réussite
éducative des élèves notamment les plus
vulnérables d'entre eux dont la
scolarité souple souffre terriblement du
confinement les classes rouvriront dans
des conditions sanitaires strictes pas
plus de 15 élèves par classe une vie
scolaire organisée autour du respect des
règles barrière de mesures d'hygiène
strictes et de la distribution de gel
hydroalcoolique tous les enseignants et
encadrants des établissements scolaires
recevront des masques qu'ils devront
porter quand ils ne pourront respecter
les règles de distanciation sur la
question des masques pour les enfants
les avis scientifiques nous ont conduits
aux décisions suivantes
le port du masque est prohibé pour les
enfants en maternelle il n'est pas
recommandé
compte tenu des risques de mauvais usage
à l'école élémentaire
mais l'éducation nationale mettra des
masques pédiatrique à disposition des
directeurs d'école pour les cas
particuliers par exemple si un enfant
présentait au cours d'une journée des
symptômes le temps que ses parents
viennent le récupérer
enfin nous fournirons des masques aux
collégiens qui peuvent emporter et qui
n'auraient pas réussi à se procurer le
port du masque pour les collégiens étant
obligatoire un intense travail de
préparation doit avoir doit avoir lieu
dans chaque académie afin que nous
puissions préparer cette rentrée
évidemment très particulière les enfants
devront pouvoir suivre une scolarité
soit au sein de leur établissement
scolaire dans les limites maximales de
15 élèves par classe sur les dix soit
chez eux avec un enseignement à distance
qui restera gratuit bien entendu soit en
étude
si les locaux scolaires le permettent ou
dans des locaux périscolaires mis à la
disposition par les collectivités
territoriales si elles le souhaitent
pour des activités de sport santé de
culture ou de civisme
j'ai admiré la mobilisation de
l'éducation nationale pendant le
confinement le dévouement de milliers
d'enseignants qui se sont mobilisés pour
accueillir les enfants de soignants qui
resteront accueilli bien entendu dans
les temps qui viennent
l'ingéniosité de tous ceux qui se sont
réinventés pour offrir à leurs élèves
des modalités original d'enseignement à
distance et nous avons tous j'en suis
sûr autour de nous des exemples
extraordinaire d'inventivité
d'engagement d'imagination pour que le
lien essentiel entre le maître et son
élève demeure alors même que la période
de confinement était en vigueur
je veux laisser le maximum de souplesse
aux terrains en la matière et je sais
que c'est ainsi que les directeurs
d'école les parents d'élèves des
collectivités locales trouverons
ensemble avec pragmatisme les meilleures
solutions
je leur dis que nous les soutiendrons et
que je leur fais confiance
les crèches seront règle également
réouverte l'accueil par groupe de 10
enfants maximum sera possible avec la
possibilité d'accueillir plusieurs
groupes de dix enfants
si l'espace le permet et si les
conditions sont réunies pour que les
groupes ne se croisent pas cette
réduction des capacités posera au moins
dans un premier temps la question des
priorités d'accueil les crèches
accueillent déjà les enfants selon des
critères économiques et sociaux et il
n'appartient pas à l'état de définir ces
critères à la place des gestionnaires il
me semble néanmoins que l'impossibilité
de télétravail pour un couple d'actifs
ou les difficultés rencontrées par les
familles monoparentales devront être
prises en compte dans ces critères les
enfants des soignants et des professeurs
devraient également à mon avis être
prioritaire le port du masque grand
public sera obligatoire pour les
professionnels de la petite enfance
puisque les règles de distanciation
physique ne peuvent pas y être appliquée
bien sûr bien sûr il n'y aura pas de
port du masque pour les enfants de moins
de 3 ans